oh
ice cream conversation in the chat
what flavors we got going on
i hope folks are having a um
a nicer day
than me it i'm
i'm tired without it um
being like a physical exhaustion thing
just like
for how much i got done versus how much
i was trying to get done
and how much i still have to do that
absolutely can't wait uh until tomorrow
i'm just
tired
so uh
that's where i'm coming at
i hope
folks are
doing better and if you're not then um
you know what allow me to uh recommend
hydrating
ben
ms wicked wolf hey carowind
pirates rowan
castile
homebody
doctor master i'm not i'm not sure if
i'm getting that right but i'll try
uh paul
logan
lots of folks hello hello hello
uh
i'm watching this and also lilo and
stage at the same time
and so on and so forth i can't hydrate
until i know my oldest has arrived from
work after i pick him up
fair
getting drunk tonight drunk no
no i have too much to do
after this is over
to get drunk
i am however attempting
desperately
to unwind
but
hope folks had a nice weekend um
wait stitch also says misa
he says that it's part of a complete
alien sentence not as broken english the
way jar jar uses it um so don't don't
worry too much about it
um
but on friday
um i went to
uh the drive-in with liz we saw the
suicide squad review for that will be
out later this evening that review's
currently rendering um as i speak
and we also saw cruella
because the drive-in does double
features
and hot damn that
that movie
i oh
i need to shoot a review for that uh
and i just i can't even i can't even
crew up my reaction to corella is the
embodiment of i can't even
it's it's so something i don't know
uh oh it's just pronounced doctor master
okay cool uh what's historical event or
person you like seen in doctor who
see i'm not a great person to ask that
because i don't like the historicals
most of the time
um
there there's some that i like
um but
by and large like i tend to dread them
so i don't like
i'm never hoping for them so i'm a bad
person to ask for oh where'd be a good
setting for historical because i'd say
like why are we going to a historical
let's let's go to space and
meet i don't know
a plant alien or something i you know
that's that's just that's not where my
uh
uh that's not where my brain goes in the
first place
loved gorilla that's fine like i can
you're not the only one i like jessie
loves it
i get why people like it
but
dude
chardelles have you already changed my
username in case you couldn't tell
well now that um unfortunately that begs
me to ask what it used to be which i
hope is not requesting a dead name
because i'm not entirely sure of the um
situation there hi molly good to see you
those grandma glasses you're wearing
well as i am not currently a grandparent
no
no
their dad glasses by default
um
cruella seemed like joker but disney to
me it's really not
it's it is its own thing
its own
bizarre
insane thing
i really enjoyed the soundtrack and the
styles mostly i love emma stone and emma
thompson okay
i get that
but can i say something about the
soundtrack
i swear they just got a greatest hits of
the 60s
and just put it on shuffle
and if it just so happened to drop a
a song for a needle drop that did not
match what was going on the scene
they said screw it and lea and left it
in
like why the hell was car wash on that
soundtrack
that was the one that broke my brain
like it has the
super obvious
um
needle drops that you expect like these
boots are made for walk-in like of
course
but you know when it when it started
playing car wash i was just like wait
what
what
why
what
will you be doing an overdue review of
corella no it's recent enough that goes
under recent-ish reviews recent
recent-ish releases
i've missed a number of uh
comments directed at me that have
scrolled past in the chat i'm not
backing them up so you can ask them
again
uh and a fight between yanto and ten who
would win
i mean
ten would
i all due respect to yanto ten as is one
of the trixiest uh of doctors
60's gorilla looks more 70s to me from
what i've seen the trails like early 70s
like it's 60s 70s it's that it's that
cusp
but like and like the soundtrack is good
music but i'm like
what
why
why why some of these choices
uh
between the bad batch and the
mandalorian being fine at best would it
be fair to say the star wars shows are
failing to grab you yeah
which
i mean that's i'm okay with that like i
did see here's the thing that's not like
that's not something for me to get upset
over
because honestly
the
star wars stuff outside of the films has
never really grabbed me
so you know i remember the 90s not being
grabbed by the novels in the comics and
like so not being grabbed by the shows
whatever this is this is old hat for me
so i'm not taking it personally i'm not
saying like stars has become something i
don't like no it's a branch of star wars
i don't care for i didn't care for it
when it was in other formats so there
you go
i'd love doctor to tackle the toxicity
of nostalgia
it's in a unique position to be able to
do that i do wonder um
it's a delicate thing to try and do
because the kind of thing that if you do
it badly you end up with another 11
monsters
so
um what are your thoughts on jar jar
binks
yeah
not the worst thing about that movie
that's the nicest thing i will say about
him uh which is worse cruella or
maleficent um
see here's the thing
i'm not sure either is actually bad
but i also would not call either one
good and there are also
very different reasons for why they fall
that way
so i honestly don't know how to compare
those two
even though you'd think it would be easy
to do because they're both disney
villain prequels but they really are
completely different beasts top to
bottom
i will say i think cruella benefits more
from
pretty much completely detaching itself
from the original source material
whereas i think maleficent trying to
offer itself up as
um
an alternate version of the story we
already knew
and tying itself more directly to the
original narrative the way it did it
led to some of the weaker parts of that
movie
so i guess cruella is at least a little
bit more self-assured in what it is than
i think melissa maleficent like forgets
what movie it is
uh for most of the second act
it's got an amazing first act and pretty
decent third act but the second act is
like
they forgot what movie they were making
so i suppose squirrel is better on that
merit
but that's that's less uh
that's less an abject quality well
that's less of my subjective
take on it and a bit more of a um
just like it's more cohesive so like i'm
having to go to more objective measures
because my own personal subjective is
oh oh we got super chats uh new type jb
lee thank you very very much you get a
heart
gutentag
uh
hope uh you're doing well
superhero question in the ncu how do you
feel about spidey getting support from
stark doesn't it go against the original
working-class appeal
of spider-man
um
i don't
think it does because like the thing is
peter's um
issues are are
still very rooted in the same kinds of
issues that peter has always had because
like
the reason i don't think it undermines
that is because
the tech ultimately doesn't solve his
problems
you know he gets better tech from tony
and he gets bailed out of one situation
one time
but
the tech ultimately doesn't fix
the issues he has going on
and so i don't think that tech ever
takes away
and pulls away from the core of
spider-man which is
somebody who is perpetually in over his
head
i mean that's that is who peter parker
is ultimately someone who's barely
keeping his head above water on
any number of levels be it as a
superhero be it in social life be it
financially
whatever he is barely holding it
together and that's still true even when
stark backs him up with tech so now i i
think i think that still holds
night night mirrors hmm
you my friend you get a heart
do you think the doctor
uh ever be trans in some way non-binary
gender fluid or any of the like i would
not be shocked
if at some point in the future i'm not
putting a date on this i'm not going to
say like within the next
x
number of years but i would not be
surprised if we get
a non-binary doctor at some point in the
future that would not surprise me
i don't think they'll ever do
trans just because
there's already a very muddied
gender thing going on
uh with just the regenerations a
sandwich under fluid but i think non-v i
think non-binary is incredibly doable
and there's really no reason not to
other than you know just not having
faith in the idea or being afraid of
certain backlash but narratively there's
absolutely no reason not to do um
non-binary because it's it's not gonna
feel muddied by just the nature of time
lords and
uh regeneration the way trans or gender
fluid would just to some degrees
ah
let's see
kent state would just want to say hi
well hiya to you too daniel
thanks for stopping in
it was a professional mentorship between
stark and parker if anything stark
wanted him to stay small and only stay
in queens well that was certainly true
in the first uh spider-man film if
nothing else um
trying to think uh
a villain i feel as underrated as ultron
because you don't really see cold
emotionless machine ai villains anymore
um
uh which i feel is a shame i i liked
ultron as a villain uh the movie doesn't
quite pull together i i feel like i can
also see the
pieces of there haven't been more to
ultron than what we got but you know
what we got is what we got um
as is canon and doctor who each new
regeneration is a whole new person not
just a face but everything changes they
just have the same memory so the doctor
could can be anything like that's true
there's no reason that any incarnation
of the doctor couldn't be gender fluid
or couldn't be trans
um
i just
the only reason i'm hesitant about doing
either one of those is
because
the nature
the the fantastical nature of the
regeneration
already lends itself to a certain amount
of trans and gender fluid readings and
then literalizing it for a specific
incarnation it just it makes things
murky
um which again does not uh
does not exclude that from being doable
or viable or feasible it's just i think
it's part of the reason why
those are far less likely to happen
someone said cruella would have been
perfect if it ended at the fashion show
with her and the coat staring at the
baroness and holding up the locket
credits
i mean it would have been a very
incomplete movie if it had been that i
mean like the first thing you need to
realize if you're gonna watch cruella
this is not cruella deville from the
movie it's not it's not even like
a new interpreter like this is so it is
a completely different person
with the same damn name
so like you need to banish
the cartoon iteration of cruella from
your head completely because it does not
fit and to its credit the movie does a
lot of things to make it as clear as
possible this is not the same
you know
so it does its best with that but man
that thing
oh man
so
okay
uh rebecca wolfe is laying out an
alternate version of tangled with
13
and sasha
timeless child the lost princess i
i mean
you could but i mean you're just you're
wrapping something that i don't like and
sticking it into something i do so
uh if your species has transcended
gender why would one even be trans
there are feasible answers to that
um
but
they would be ones that would probably
need to be addressed and then it would
be the fear of whether or not the show
could address them well
random comic fact about ultron he tried
to blow himself up after reading the
phrase thou shalt not kill
he's so murder happy that the thought of
not killing drove him to suicide
oh yeah
that's why i like this version of koala
i was worried because i didn't know if i
could like a movie about the backstory
of a woman who killed puppies
um that they changed it made me like it
like i get that but at the same time
like it is so divorced from it
that it like
really all it borrows is certain
aesthetic things like the hair
which for some
reason
it like
explains like now
cruella's half white half black hair
thing is something she was born with and
teased over and has to hide as opposed
to being
clearly the fashion choice of a deranged
human
like that that that right there the that
thing i just did that was me through
most of the movie like okay i don't want
to give spoilers on this but when
the thing happens at the start
to her mother
if you've seen the movie you know the
thing
when that happened
i just about died laughing
and here's the thing
i knew it was coming
i'd heard about that
but still seeing it
like
what what
i want to be in the room i want to be in
the room where the pitch meeting
happened where that scene was pitched i
want to hear the sales pitch that got
anybody to sign off on that idea like
what
[Laughter]
not even thinking about it now
oh jesus
it's just
oh
oh that movie
god
where'd you get that brown wig you used
to wear i don't know i had a couple of
brown wigs either at a wig shop in new
york or amazon roll or die i don't know
isaac thank you for the super chat isaac
barrett thank you very much
do you stand by your new who ranking
idiot slandered so at the bottom and the
doctor dances top if not then what
replaced it love your channel by the way
um idiots bottom
idiots bottom
idiot's lantern definitely still at the
bottom i
i will be very surprised
if anything ever knocks idiot's lantern
out of the bottom spot
because idiot's lantern is not just bad
idiot slanted i find
offensive
and
harmful
i find the
ending of that
episode to be [ __ ]
hazardous
i hate it and it's not right
so
for something to ever end up lower
than
idiots lantern the show's gonna have to
screw up
in ways that i'm not even prepared to
fathom thinking about
that's what would have to happen
for somebody to take over that bottom
spot
top see the thing is the top has always
been a fluid thing
because what sits at the top depends on
when you ask me
because sometimes
it's the doctor dances
sometimes it's the doctor falls
sometimes it's
the force of the dead
um
sometimes it's midnight you know there's
there's a there's a rotating
stable
of
things like in in my top five or so that
um
that shift around
um so you know
that that one's never uh never a
permanent thing
slower than even arachnids in the uk
iraqis in the uk is just stupid
idiot's lantern is dangerous
and i mean that like that's not a word i
use lightly the message and the note
that it ends on with rose telling a
teenager to go and reconnect with his
toxic father who just
barely left the house he has not
possibly had enough time to even
consider his actions or why he was
thrown out of the house and rose sends a
child back to his abuser and i get why
rose does it because she's got daddy
issues but the episode itself frames it
like it's a good idea and
no
no no no a thousand times and forever no
that is wrong and that is
harmful
that idea of well you you have to it's
your dad no you do not
whoever it is
if somebody is that damaging to you to
your life to your family to your mental
stability you are in your right to cut
them out do not encourage an abused
person to go back and get in touch with
their abuser
i can't even talk about that episode
without getting really upset
i and look from any
[Music]
from any notion of
narrative
from any notion of a worse constructed
story
worse acting yes you can find worst
episodes of doctor who than the idiot's
lantern
but
i cannot think of another episode that
has a
message or an idea
at the heart of it or that it ends on in
this case that is more harmful than that
and this is this isn't something that i
can just brush off as
they i think they screwed up and didn't
think about what they were doing because
like you could make arguments for there
being some really dodgy uh ethics and
messaging kerblam
and you wouldn't even be wrong but i can
look at that and go i'm not sure they
realize the implications which doesn't
make it okay
but it stops me from getting angry
but they should have known
they wrote this story they wrote this
character this
father
as this
horrible atrocious toxic human being
even wrote a scene of the son standing
up to him and then within the same scene
have rose encourage him
to go and make sure he doesn't lose
contact
that
no i can't i can't
i can't let that pass on the idea of
they just they just made a whoopsie
no
no you had to have had a
concussion to think that was a good
goddamn idea
uh
night oh god
nightmares
oh my gosh thank you
so much
thank you for that
i feel you should dr who pick up
on the whole idea that the doctor's
clone since the confession dial
could explain why there's other doctors
pre-heart knowledge they fabricated a
story for the clone and the real one is
with wrath along somewhere secret
here's the thing look as much as i
hate the timeless child thing and i do
hate it
um
i don't want them to recon it
because by and large
corrective retcons
meant to undo something
i think are almost never worth it
i think
like sometimes you have to write con to
bring a character back
fair enough but like if you're just
trying to retcon an event that you or
fans didn't like
i always tend to feel that the effort
that goes into that
the effort that goes and the effort and
the thought and the creativity and the
time
the story time where we could be getting
news stories moving forward that instead
is being spent looking back trying to
fix a problem
i think is better spent moving forward
i think it is
better if something happened that sucks
to the best of your ability ignore it
don't talk about it don't dwell on it
just move
forward because
going back and trying to
fix these old things like that's that's
at the heart of most of the worst
continuity
nonsense from the dc comics
and i'm very much afraid now that the
flash movie's actually happening that
that's going to end up on the films too
so
did you ever finish avatar the last
airbender legend of korra
hmm
no i didn't
and no i didn't
uh and i'm i'm a little bit afraid to
say why but
uh cell specs your uh video on luca and
her review about the movie i saw that
she actually asked me if it was okay to
do that um
before she put it up so yeah i knew
about that
um
uh
so hang on uh
let's call the doctor variance like in
loki again that's like over complicating
things just to try and make a thing go
away like just just move on just move
forward
if you don't want to deal with it don't
deal with it move forward
like that's
that's what the show did after the
freaking movie with the eighth doctor
was like oh the doctor's half human let
us never speak of this thing again
so you know
big finish have made a lot of canon
fixing story best case scenario they're
good because of other stuff they tell an
interesting story in spite of it now see
i don't mind canon fixing in ancillary
works
side things comics novels the audio
whatever the main um oh hi steven uh
whatever the main um
format for the thing is in the case of
doctor who it is the shows i don't want
that getting bogged down in continuity
nonsense
i i don't ever want that
so
um
i don't have a problem with big finish
or other places doing it go ahead go
nuts because like the nature of that
stuff is it's optional if i don't if i
don't feel like
bogging myself down with continuity
nonsense i can skip it and not feel like
i'm missing out on the essential
experience you start doing that in the
main show and that's not the case
anymore
ah aj schultz thank you thank you very
very much i appreciate that immensely
the most concise way i've seen my
thoughts on this era framed was that
chibnall had a responsibility to write
the first female doctor well and failed
any thoughts love your stuff by the way
keep it up um
i don't like the phrasing on that
because
i don't think the issues with chibnall's
writing have anything to do with the
fact that it's the first female doctor
i i think he wrote the doctor
in the way that he was going to write
any doctor
um i don't think
that the characterization would be
significantly different if it wasn't a
woman
so i don't
something doesn't sit right with me
about
um pairing
the responsibility of a first female
doctor and his bad writing together
because they're
well while you're not wrong in that
any major milestone first doctor
probably deserved better um
but
you know what the milestone was the
doctor being a woman
is really completely separate from all
the problems
with his era so i i just don't like
linking
the two as talking points if that makes
sense
um
have any doctor who stories influenced
or made you think about your writing
um
probably not in any way i'm i'm
conscious of oh jp hagerty thank you
so very much folks are very generous
tonight i i really do appreciate that
after after what the day has been that's
that's been kind of necessary
uh
agreed about idiots lantern another
issue i have with it also the victory of
the daleks is the overt british
nationalistic propaganda and the doctor
being pro-monarchy and pro-churchill
yeah
when and then this is
part of the
hazard
um
of
of
the historical stuff especially when
they are dealing with
um
when they're dealing with british
figures
which is that the characters i mean
they're the people rather
because they're real-life people aren't
held to the same
standard that the doctor judges other
people
like
if there wasn't a reason to write the
doctor
as being in favor of churchill i.e it's
a british show made by the bbc for a
british audience
churchill's not the kind of guy the
doctor would be friends with
the monarchy in general not really
something he'd support that much
especially at this point when it's
freaking ceremonial
like what
he
it the structure
of
a lot of the uk's recent history is not
something that if you
separate out what actually happens what
these people actually do what their
historical contributions are i'm not
saying he'd be 100 against them
but
the doctor the doctor would not be
friends with winston churchill
like he wouldn't
not an accurate portrayal of winston
churchill at any rate
uh have you heard of a movie called
america in motion
uh picture if not all i'll say uh
it
it was an arm mounted chainsaw george
washington versus werewolf benedict
arnold oh
i did hear about that i saw
i saw trailers i forgot that that was
coming out
i totally forgot about that
uh
churchill and peacetime wasn't nice well
churchill and wartime wasn't nice the
difference the difference being that
wartime churchill you kind of needed a
guy who wasn't nice
in those circumstances at that time with
who they were facing
churchill was never nice
um it's just there was there was a very
narrow setting in which
the nature of who the man was
was
appropriate
or at least
well deployed
let's go with that churchill was the war
doctor
uh
i don't think churchill would have
stopped himself pushing the button so
i'm not sure i buy that
stories that have influenced my own
writing sound
drums amy's choice dr falls hell bent
make of that what you will i think what
why it's hard for me to nail down how
much um
doctor who has or hasn't influenced my
writing is i don't write um
much science fiction
so it's hard to make uh
the direct comparisons to a lot of what
doctor who does to my own writing um
i've written like one science fiction
short story which i'm very proud of uh
not particularly doctor who inspired
um
let's see you think an american werewolf
in london the exorcist and the shining
or overrated any more beloved horror
movies you think are overrated yeah
probably
i mean there are lots of horror movies
that are popular for a nostalgia reason
and like american werewolf in london
and the exorcist are both fine the
shining is bad the shining's a bad movie
it's bad it's a bad movie made by a bad
man who did bad things
but um
american werewolf in london the
exorcists are fine but you know
overrated is the word overrated does not
mean bad
let us not forget something can be very
good but if it was sold to you by other
people as being
of higher quality than what you got it's
still overrated even if you're like no
that was very good
the comparison i've made before is if
you go to a restaurant and your friend
said order the steak it'll be the best
steak you have ever had in your life if
you order that steak and it's anything
other than that then you can safely say
it's overrated it can be an excellent
steak but if it's not the best steak you
ever had in your life it's
overrated king hated the shiny it's
nothing like the book that's not why
it's a bad movie
it's a bad movie because it's a bad
movie
i never read the book i don't care to
read the book i don't care if it's
different from the book i don't care if
anything's different from the book
fidelity to a book does not make or
break a movie it's a bad movie because
it's a bad movie
i feel bad for shelley duvall i hope
she's getting the help that she needs i
mean honestly
she should be getting an annual stipend
from kubrick's
estate
at minimum
prefer the omen over the exorcist i
actually never saw the omen all the way
through
who are some of your other youtube
friends new to your channel well like
folks who i've actually like
um
had conversations with
um that would be folks like bag full
jessie gender
um
phillip hawkins
uh i'm gonna forget some
uh the who chaser
um
uh i've had a couple conversations with
jxe but i think that might be
overstepping to say that that we're
friends but like we're friendly
um that's the thing i'm trying to decide
where the line is
um oh uh passion of the nerd
ian good guy
um have you seen the tv series hannibal
starring mads mickelson i have and it's
great
are you more a fan of the newer doctor
who or the older one um
i don't have a clean answer for that
because there are certain aspects of
doctor who that i feel have been lost
in the modern era
that i miss from classic but like i'd be
lying if i said i like the story
structure and the pacing and the look of
classic more than modern because i don't
um but there are definitely things about
um classic era who that
broadly speaking
i
i like and i kind of wish we could bring
back
um
i'm not sure we can at this point with
some of it but yeah
i like your chill take on doctor who i'm
usually chill i'm not always chill
but
i i i
i try to have it be
if i get worked up i try to have it be
for a reason
ah
nightmares again thank you
thank you so much
i hope doctor who does some great things
with whitaker's last arc by great i mean
not overly offensive like give the
writer a god complex
like
i always want doctor who to be good
especially this is going to be our last
series i want it to be
great
but
i don't know if i can trust that it will
be but i want it to be very much
what's up with avatar the last airbender
i didn't finish the second season cause
i am
i realized i didn't care
sorry
so there's that bomb dropped
see how many
subscribers i now immediately lose
i'd love it if the centennial special
was a hitchhiker's crossover thoughts
that would be awesome not a chance but
that would be awesome
if you ever make a video of a list of
the movies you hate but everyone else
loves how would you rank them i don't
know like that idea has been on my idea
board for a while
um
but i don't know if i'll ever get around
to it the problem with that is like it
seems a little too self-indulgent
for me at least from where i'm at these
days watch avatar watch
look okay
look here's the thing
i watched the first season of avatar
i thought it was fine i thought it was
pretty good i didn't think it was as
good as a lot of people made it out to
be i totally understand why when it
aired in what 2004 wyatt blew a lot of
people's minds and why it was a major
stepping stone and a massive inspiration
for years and years and years to come i
get all of that i cannot watch it with
the context of seeing it fresh for the
first time in 2004. i have to watch it
with the context of seeing a bunch of
stuff that was inspired by it and i
would argue surpassed it
so it's going back and seeing a slightly
less refined version of things i already
like seeing
the less evolved form see where a lot of
things that i've enjoyed in more recent
shows come from and appreciate oh that's
that's where some places got this but
that doesn't mean i'm going to enjoy it
as much as the newer stuff so i kind of
appreciate it from an archaeological
bent
but i just thought it was fine
and i did a review of the first season
and said as much
as what i just said there
and people were pretty gentle
about it but i noticed nearly everyone
uh
who commented on you know on the fact
that i didn't like it as much as maybe
people seem to think i should
all said oh we'll just wait till you get
to the second season
and then i watched the second season
and i got to the finale last one or two
episodes and i realized this thing's
almost over
and i don't think any better of it than
when i finished the first season
and
i don't want to sit down and make a
video about how this thing that everyone
loves isn't working for me
if i'd hated it that could have given me
some motivation
you know i didn't
it's fine it's good i see why it's good
but
i've just it doesn't grab me and i've
got no passion about the thing positive
or negative
and i just felt like i'm gonna have
nothing to say
if i talk about this
and it's just gonna be me
trying to justify to people who already
love this thing
why i don't and that's not
the kind of content i
i like to make
you know
i think the kicker was so many people
told me i was gonna love toff
and
i kind of hated her
like i started to realize that like what
people like about this just isn't
gelling
with me
and again i see what's good
i see
how it's good and definitely for the
time it came out i see why it is seminal
for so many people but just f
i don't plan to i don't plan to go back
and finish it i just
does avatar have the same issues as
watching the matrix now possibly i mean
i saw the matrix when it first came out
so i'm i'm on the flip side of that one
because i'm old
um
have you ever seen the works of david
firth creator of salad fingers i've seen
a couple of episodes of salad fingers i
don't see think i've seen
uh
any of his other stuff
question is shira the princess of power
um
the reason
is uh she's on the princess of power
good the reason i haven't seen it is
because the art style kind of threw me
off i mean it is stylized i think she
wrote the princess of power is great
i think it's phenomenal
but you know
you know the phrase is there's no
accounting for taste
and if
uh if the visual
um
presentation of it is something you
can't get over
i mean i i can't the visual
style is not going to change that's not
something i can tell excuse me i can
tell you will get better
it is what it is
and if you don't think you can power
through it
then fair enough
iro is the best character yes
yes
i will agree with that
iro is the best character
partly because he's voiced by mako who
was
amazing what do you think of donnie
darko oh god what a self-important
donnie darko when i first saw it i
remember like all my friends were
falling over themselves going like it's
so brilliant and i watched him went it's
okay
and time has not been kind to that thing
especially as richard kelly has made
other movies and you realize he made a
decent movie uh with donnie darko by
accident
his own director's cut shows that he
does not understand why his own movie
was decent
so yeah that's that's not a movie that
is that has
stood the test of time very well at all
uh to the people that drink like fruit
tea and stuff can you add milk to it i'm
confused ugh i hate fruit teas
i like herbal teas i hate fruit teas
shouldn't taste like fruit
uh
what's your most favorite ncis episode
ah you're funny
which accent is better bert and mary
poppins are horus in cruella
uh reposted this with the character
names as i fear the surname of bert's
character is getting this blocked
um
i don't know about the accent
i like taurus and cruella the best thing
about cruella was wink
and then
um
horus by association
so
you know
uh
hang on i'm trying to check something
here
i feel about donnie darko the same way
family i felt about the godfather it
insists upon itself
yeah
[Music]
fair
fair
you should see southland tales it's even
more incomprehensible no that's not
that's not a good sales pitch
um
not much on the discord but you should
check it okay i'll give it a look heroin
thank you for the reminder
yeah not as much going on uh
in the discord uh for the live stream
prep the discord's still a lovely place
and a reminder it is a patreon exclusive
perk
um
just wanted to say hello from panama oh
that was sweet
uh and also i have to say happy birthday
online to someone but then i'll join
well i hope somebody had a lovely
birthday song to them
uh
i will fight for kill bill i like to
kill bill i like kill bill quite a bit
what's your favorite biscuit or cookie
um
as i've gotten older you know what i've
started to realize i really like
shortbread
yeah
it's like it's not so sweet that after
like having
two it's like cloying at my throats like
it's really
good shortbread is really well balanced
yeah that's kind of where i'm at these
days
and it dunks really well into stuff so
that's a bonus
uh
i saw the fall in my film class and
is now my favorite film of all time the
fall is really good
um
that felt like um
that i feel like a little bit like with
richard kelly and um donnie darko i feel
like um i can't think his name now but
the guy who directed the fall he
stumbled into making a great movie
because like you look at any of his
other movies they are visually gorgeous
and
storytelling so when he made a movie
that was actually about
telling a story and making it
you know this
absolutely ridiculous thing and that
just leaned into his
his strength set he created something
really amazing but i think it's just
because he stumbled across something
that really fit his skill set
um i'm not sure he i don't think he'll
ever make anything that good again
uh did you watch the old danny k movies
court jester knock on wood the only
danny k movie i've seen is white
christmas
um
and whenever i think of danny k
um i think of the the song in that movie
choreography
or starts with you know this very over
dramatic
you know dance pieces there with the you
know with the eyeliner on
the theater the theater
what's happened to the theater he's
uh he's fun in that i liked him
what's your weirdest food combo that
nobody else likes
uh oh
i don't know
i mean i don't know if it counts as a
combo i'll just use pickle juice as a
chaser to drinking shots but
i don't know if that counts as a combo
the thing that threw me off about the
art style is the character design
everyone looks like a freaking twig even
she-ra uh which is why i love master of
the universe's art style well i mean you
say that you go back to the
to the old um
[Music]
shura cartoons they they were pretty
spendly
um
i mean part of the thing to remember
with the sheila and the princess of
power is they are all supposed to be
teenagers
the core cast
so part of that
um part of that
thinness of limb let's go with that um
is to evoke a uh a sense of youth
and again if it doesn't work for you
that's fine
uh
inglorious passage is my favorite
tarantino movie probably entirely
because of the opening scene in kristoff
vaults crystal vaults was really good
i mean going asbestos was fine like
there's never been a tarantino movie
that i've watched more than once
so that's kind of where i'm at with him
uh just in general
there are times i think those who are
against background checks for god
purchases
um are from people who know they
wouldn't pass a background check to get
a gun um i disagree
hey here's the
here's the thing about gun control
in the u.s
the lack of gun could and this is what's
some of what's infuriating about the
political system here
the
gun the lack of gun control
is not because most people don't want
gun control most people do to some
degree want more gun control than we
currently have a
more than solid majority
but
the people who don't
are highly organized
and highly motivated
the nra
has fewer members than planet fitness
but it rally them
to a single issue
anywhere in the country and all they
have to do
is just say no
they don't have to offer an alternate
plan they don't have to explain why
something would or would work all they
have to do is say no
and they do
and they do it very efficiently
they are not even close to being a major
they're they're so far away from a
majority it's absurd
but the people who have drawn a hard
line
over that issue for a variety of reasons
because i've met i've met some
what i can only call hardcore second
amendment enthusiasts
your suggestion
um
i was going to say sells them short i
think it misunderstands them
because it presumes that they are
attempting to directly benefit
themselves in a way like i i want a gun
uh and this might prevent me personally
from having a gun
it
that's
the reasons are deeper than that
fundamentally people who are really
hardcore into the second amendment
have a deep
distrust
what of
will vary from person to person
some it's the government in general
some it's the left in specific some
it's foreigners some it's any number of
things but there is a deep deep deep
distrust of something
and a belief that a day may come that
the only way that they can defend what
they think this country should be
is
at
is by
taking up arms
and that's why they fight gun control
because not because they're like i want
a gun it's because
somewhere at some level they believe
that
them having a gun
will mean that they will win
some conflict that they
believe will happen
so
it's
it is deeper and more involved and more
twisted
sadly
uh new type jb lee
heart for you another comic question how
do you feel about marvel refusing to
ever let peter grow up whether it's the
marriage the divorce or even being a
widower uh drives me nuts
actually
um as much as i love spider-man
spider-man is is probably my favorite
superhero like
unabashed superhero because like there's
anti-heroes and
you know some other things that where it
gets a little bit um
more wavered but
it does irritate me that
the movies have never let spider-man
move past school
like as much as i love tom holland he's
my favorite person to portray peter
parker i'm
when he was cast i was immediately
frustrated like just let spider-man be a
goddamn adult
and
i
it here's the thing it's not just
spider-man and with spider-man it's far
more obvious because to roll him back to
an to an earlier status quo is to
basically make out like he's a teenager
again
um
but
with um
[Music]
with
peter it just becomes more evident but
it it happens with so many so many
characters look at batman
he was supposed to marry catwoman well
according scott king
thought it was a good idea to lie that
that he was going to do that when he was
never planning to
idiot
but you know they don't let these
characters they don't let any superhero
like stay in a couple you have to break
them up you have to make them say you
have to revert them back to their iconic
status
and
in the case of spider-man as i said
that's more immediately evident and
obvious
when they do that
but it's a problem with honestly any
long-running story
that
um
is only allowed to grow so much
that eventually they'll just roll it
back to an earlier point
in some way
so
yes that ticks me off about spider-man
but that that's an inherent problem with
long-running serial
fiction which is what
uh superhero comics are
excuse me what's your favorite in sync
song i don't have one next question
question favorite kind of humor mine are
puns irony and a little bit of ranch
um
i've always been partial to word play
and snappy banter
uh
i think
uh i might wrap it up soon uh speaking
of spider-man and gun control
uh why did stark give weapons of mass
destruction to a teenager
you know
maybe maybe he uh
maybe got into the wine cellar again
uh are you a fan of any modern anime or
is it not your thing i like
i haven't gotten into too many animes
because a i don't have the time and b
anime fandom scares me
if i can be completely honest about it
what's your favorite film scores of the
last 10 years um
i think tron legacy falls in that range
so
that one
other than that uh film scores it's been
a while since they grabbed me oh um
how to train your dragon two had a
really great score so the first one um
but that one's over a decade old now
um
those are off the top of my head
velcro what a ripoff
nice
uh the guy in american werewolf playing
chess against brian glover uh who is
maybe one line is a young actor named
rick male and he has become the most
famous person in that movie i know that
name
why do i know that name
i love brian glover though brian glover
is
like he's just
he's so perfect for those kinds of parts
and let's see i know that name i don't
know wine rick
my all
the young ones i never watched the young
ones
um
oh
drop dead fred that guy
okay
um
yeah not um
i mean i'm sure he's done decent stuff
nothing that i'm um
i have seen
but okay
what are your thoughts on disney's peter
pan not one i have the particular desire
to go back and see that's about all i've
got
um
he was in shock treatment
oh i barely remember shock treatment at
this point
yeah
anyways
but
there's a comment that just says bottom
are you identifying as one are you
asking if i'm one are you accusing me of
being one
don't threaten me with a good time
[Music]
my read of dr falls is a commentary on
this kind of treatment of long-running
characters
they keep getting reset
arguably
uh what makes anime fandom scary
uh
there are no small opinions in anime
everything is the best or the worst and
fandoms that intense
they they they can put me off
um
rick my was in bottom okay i don't know
what that is i'd like
the only thing that anyone's name that i
know anything about is drop dead fred
haven't seen it didn't want to i've
heard of the young ones i don't i never
watched it like i don't know any of this
stuff i'm sorry i'm sorry a new type jb
lee thank you once again
wonder if your issues with peter's
stagnation is more frustration
by the success of miles and spider gwen
who are better examples of youthful
spidey
um
i'm not sure that
uh
that's a
cause of it but that is uh that does
exacerbate it because like
you have characters to give you the
young
you know take on spider-man you don't
need to keep resetting peter so
yeah the their existence frustrates the
issue
um but i don't think that's the cause of
it because i i had this complaint before
i got into either of their stuff
bottom was a sitcom that he wrote in
star wars with adrian edmondson who was
the first order guy
with the most lines in the last jedi i
only watched the last jedi once so i'm
not even sure who that was oh my god
you're all just giving me reference
point where i'm like i don't know i
don't know
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know
how
uh
was also lord
flash heart and blackadder
i
vaguely remember that
very vaguely
anyways
i think
i think i'm going to uh
i think i'm going to wrap it up
so
thank you everybody for
joining me
uh i hope you all have a good evening
i think
the uh no no not quite yet the
suicide squad video is not yet done
rendering but that'll be up um
later this evening
uh
so
yeah
yeah we'll wrap it up there
thank you all
hope that you have a good rest of the
week
i hope that you are staying safe
and i want you to remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council
i just run the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
mckeavity